[Musique]
taking le mal qui ronge le sport
professionnel c'est quoi ton king s'est
littéralement prendre le canon d'un punk
visé le cas de la formation et en voyant
nos bus oblitéré tout ce qu'il ya de bon
dans ton équipe pour que 100 du
classement et obtenir plus de choix au
repêchage comme les sénateurs 0
exactement le tagging c'est l'idée que
la solution à la défaite si plus de
défaire avec un beau slogan pour faire
passer le tout à ses partisans on se
rappelle tous du succès de fer forgé ou
quand on parle de taking on a tous
l'image d'un pauvre partisans qui tente
d'empêcher son dg de détruire son club
sauf que taking ça fait aucunement
référence à ce genre de tongs c'est
plonger au fond d'un réservoir intègre
mais de toute façon qu'ils se soucient
encore de la provenance des vaucrises
éléphants cool le thème king c'est comme
regarder le marché de l'immobilier à
montréal et de se dire que plutôt que de
déménager dans un trois et demi à 500
mille dollars lui vous craquer une
allumette
de toute façon j'ai les assurances tout
l'apport en protéines le tanking c'est
le pari que perdre aujourd'hui permettra
des jours meilleurs demain tout en
montrant conférence de presse
l'arc en ciel que sa fille a dessiné
avec les mots ça va bien aller
c'est ce qui arrive quand tu confies ton
équipe à 1 heure des statistiques plutôt
qu'un ancien défenseur de 3e para qui
fait part avec subissait pas tous les
autres vg de la ligue pour lui donner ce
qu'il veut quand il veut mais toujours
sur les bourses le meilleur choix
le problème avec le thème king c'est que
l'espoir a remplacé la victoire l'an
dernier les jets de new york ont gagné
seulement deux marches mais c'est un
trop pour aller chercher la moustache
marc decrey voleur s'est rendu plus
difficile être la pire équipe qu être la
meilleure parce que plus des kits
désespérée que des équipes aspirantes au
titre du très inspirante
alors les équipes se démène pour être
poche mais vraiment poche
encore cette année les sabres ont perdu
18 march de suite et dans les billets
les roquettes ont fait encore mieux
28 et quand les sabres ont fini par
gagner ils ont simplement décidé de
jouer pau bâton
cette marque avec ses patins mais
évidemment qui a pas marqué il joue
comme un pied depuis dix ans l'idée du
tanking systématique a fait son chemin
dans le sport professionnel
et même si les ligues ont tenté d'y
remédier rien n'y fait l'idée est
tellement rendu commune dans le sport
professionnel qu'on attend même plus
d'être mauvais pour commencer une
reconstruction exactement le contraire
du stade olympique par les à lougansk
d'or que vu tous ces menteurs quitté
après la dernière saison par ce qui est
trop bas le problème avec le tanking
c'est que c'est comme les plans
quinquennaux du canadien si ça marche
pas sur commande
à force de perdre c'est ce que tu peux
te retrouver avec candeur mais tu peux
aussi te contenter de l'esprit qui fait
des progrès en français puisque tu pars
donc plus que temps à vie de père donc
plus que tu perds donc plus que temps à
vide perdant plus que tu pars donc plus
que temps ville pernes y en a qui
bandent aléas pour moins que ça un
message de soutien perdants aujourd'hui
c'est pour toi
partisan d'une équipe qui a décidé
d'embrasser le côté obscur du sport toi
qui porte maintenant au quotidien un sac
de papier sur la tête plutôt que la
casquette ton club préféré j'aime mon
équipe toi qui ne connaît plus les noms
des choix le ton équipe
mais qui connaît par coeur le nom des
100 premiers espoirs au prochain
repêchage toi qui doit supporter
d'entendre la direction de son club dire
on ne perd pas on investit dans le futur
tout le droit de changer de club dans
nos clients comme toi s'est rendu à la
fin de cette vidéo
grand gaillard pour célébrer ça laisse
noualhac bon sens va bientôt ciao que je
vois personne me disais que je plus beau
demain les plus gourmands
mais voilà c'était la nature